The country of Zambia lies in the center of southern Africa.
It's nowhere near an ocean, yet it's largely shaped by water.
Zambia is heavily influenced by three major rivers: the Luangwa, the Kafue, and  the great Zambezi.
The Luangwa River flows south from the northeastern end of the country.
Near the Luangwa you can find hippopotamuses or "hippos" , lions,...
...gazelles...
...and crocodiles!
The Luangwa and its banks make an excellent hunting ground for predators of all types.
Both large and small animals depend on this river to survive.
However, as more people move into wildlife areas,...
...these animal populations are beginning to be threatened.
Fortunately, the government of Zambia is protecting these important animal habitats.
Large portions of the Luangwa have been made into national parks and animal reserves.
Zambia's next major river, the Kafue, lies in the center of the country.
Around it, huge level areas of land known as the Kafue Flats have been protected as national parks and animal reserves.
Here, seasonal floods support the environment of rare types of antelope...
...as well as hundreds of species of birds.
The waters of the Kafue also provide hydroelectricity for the country and support irrigation systems for farms.
Both the Luangwa and the Kafue later join the Zambezi, Africa's fourth largest river basin.
It starts small and slow in the north of Zambia.
As it moves toward Zambia's southern edge, its water flows gently.
Here, the Zambezi serves as a kind of "water road" for nearby communities.
They use it to carry things between villages and to travel up and down the river.
But a few hundred miles down, the river becomes extremely fast and powerful.
Here, it becomes one of the world's great waterfalls.
The falling water looks like smoke and makes a lot of noise.
In the local language, it's known as the "smoke that thunders".
The rest of the world knows it as "Victoria Falls".
In 1855, British explorer Dr. David Livingstone became the first European to see Victoria Falls.
He named the waterfall after the British Queen Victoria.
The nearby town of Livingstone was named after the explorer.
It has become a main starting point for tourists who want to visit the spectacular falls.
And they are spectacular, approximately one million gallons of water go over the 355 - foot - high falls every second!
From here, the Zambezi continues its journey to the Indian Ocean.
Along the way, it's joined by the two other great rivers of Zambia: the Kafue and the Luangwa.
Together, it is these three rivers that help to make Zambia what it is today.